the state versus Richard Alexander
Murdoch defendant indictment for murder
SC code 16-3
d010 CDR code
0116 verdict
guilty now the nation was riveted by the
story for all the reasons you'd expect
was a prominent Southern family two
murders big money drugs and of course
mystery Alec Murdoch was eventually
placed at the scene of his wife and
Son's killing by an audio recording from
his dead son's phone but now Murdoch's
attorneys say that he deserves a new
trial because of jury tampering
allegedly by the clerk that you just
heard reading the verdict that the clerk
of court would go in to the sanctity of
the Jury Room Before He testified and
tell the jurors don't be fooled by his
testimony watch out for his body
language and if that is true which we
have every reason to believe that it is
and no reason to believe it it's not not
there's no choice but the courts to
Grant a new
trial joining me now Martha mcallum
anchor and executive editor of the story
she just spoke with Murdoch's surviving
son Buster for a new Fox Nation series
The Fall of the House of Murdoch
available now on Fox Nation all right
Martha this is wild um what else did
Murdoch's attorneys claim that this
clerk did I know there was a Facebook uh
reference and juror
I'm devouring all this information but
tell
us yeah you know we always knew that
dick harutan and Jim Griffin were going
to appeal this case Laura they said that
as soon as it was over but I think what
we didn't expect we thought it was going
to be along the lines of the judge
allowing all these Financial
improprieties to be part of this murder
case but what we got today was something
completely different and it was based on
Becky Hill's book she released a book of
her inside story of this case she really
became kind of a character in this whole
case and The Narrative of it so she
released this book and it talked a lot
about what happened behind the scenes
and that gave harutan and Griffin an
open door so they started going through
that door based on things that she said
like this for example we all remember
Laura when they went to the scene of the
crime right before they started
deliberating she says when all of us at
the from the courthouse law enforcement
or the jury went to Moselle we had an
epiphany and we shared our thoughts with
our eyes at that moment any of us
standing there knew I knew and they knew
that Alex was guilty okay so she's
talking about communication between the
jurors there's two jurors who say that
who told har putut in a griffin they
knocked on every juror's door they said
most of them wouldn't talk to them but
two of them say that she indicated to
them don't be fooled by Alec Murdoch she
also indicated to them according to
their sworn testimony look this isn't
isn't going to take long and then they
also say that she wouldn't allow them to
take smoke breaks during deliberations
that they couldn't smoke until they were
done now this is their side of the story
we'll see what happens when we hear the
other side of the story it could be very
very different but this is what we got
today from the defense attorneys Laura
and isn't there a claim also that some a
juror was dismissed for un on um
incorrect grounds that's another claim
that they're
making yeah this is a wild story this
jur
uh the the story is from the defense
that Becky Hill moved to have a j
removed because she saw something on
Facebook that said that the juror's
ex-husband was indicating how this juror
felt about the case she went to judge
Newman they hashed it out they ended up
removing this person from the case but
Griffin claims that the post was not
from her ex-husband at all she hadn't
communicated with him in 14 years and
that she was removed improperly from
this case but you know as you know
better than anyone Laura um we're we're
still going to wait to hear and there's
absolutely crickets coming from the
prosecution so far they say we're going
to wait we're going to review all of
this and see what it is but this this
case was a huge loss for dick carpoon
and Jim Griffin they are very big
attorneys in this part of the world and
the fact that this thing turned on them
in three hours after they went into
deliberations I you know they have been
scrambling to figure out a way to turn
this thing around but they may have
touched on something that might actually
work and produce another trial and she
may have an FBI investigation into her
Becky Hill because part of this is a
federal prosecution request or
investigation request of potential
criminal acts of tampering with a jury
and if you want to see Mar Martha's full
The Fall of the House of Murdoch special
on Fox Nation it is fantastic it's
available now Martha so great to see you
so thank you so much hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else